cette manifestation avait pour objectif
donc de parler des animaux liminaires
c'est à dire tous les animaux qui en
liberté dans l'espace urbain donc les
rames mais aussi les pigeons et donc en
fait ce sont des animaux où généralement
des gens racontent tout n'importe quoi
et en fait c'est toujours le même
méthode qui sont utilisées c'est-à-dire
des méthodes où on les tue dès lors
qu'il nous dérange et on refuse
finalement collectivement de se poser la
question de comment pourrait faire
autrement donc je vais parler des rats
parce que je sais que c'est le sujet
d'aujourd'hui et que c'est aussi ton
sujet passion comme tu veux et donc ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que
aujourd'hui en fait on utilise
massivement des méthodes de létale qui
sont cruelles qui font souffrir les rats
donc la méthode la plus utilisée par la
Mairie de Paris c'est l'empoisonnement
massif des rangs qui sont des
anticoagulants qui provoquent des
hémorragies internes alors aujourd'hui
on a un troisième génération
d'anticoagulants
il y a un dossier du jour ils ont fait
un dossier sur le les notes de frais
d'animalgo je pense que le meilleur
moyen d'éradiquer les reins c'est de lui
montrer les notes de frais
à dire même lui il va dire vous allez
voir il paraît que c'est normal on va
voir il y a Eric Revel qui viendra dans
un instant Amandine c'est juste une
petite parenthèse que tu sais je
parenthèse bien que les gens alors juste
sur les reins parce que je voudrais dire
c'est qu'on a la troisième génération
d'anticoagulants c'est-à-dire de poison
c'est à dire que les rats deviennent de
plus en plus résistants donc on a des
méthodes qui d'un côté sont cruels font
souffrir les animaux puisque les rats
souffrent et de l'autre côté on a des
méthodes qui sont inefficaces c'est à
dire que globalement tout le monde se
plaint et personne n'est satisfait donc
nous on souhaite poser la question des
méthodes non létales éthique efficace
c'est-à-dire comment faire pourquoi
habiter ensemble puisque tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire que c'est pas
possible d'éradiquer les rats et que
tant qu'il y aura des déchets de manière
massive du gaspillage alimentaire il y
aura des rats donc l'idée c'est de pour
nous l'idée c'est d'avoir des méthodes
donc à la fois sur la gestion des
déchets donc on a fait des propositions
à la mairie de Paris je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui il y a que 10% des
poubelles de rue qui sont hermétiques
donc c'est en cours de déploiement il en
faut il faut qu'elle est 100% et aussi
sur des méthodes de contraceptive donc à
New York aux États-Unis il existe un
contraceptif par voie orale donc ça
serait le même alors c'est un peu
similaire à la pilule en effet sauf que
c'est une substance qui est liquide qui
est mis dans des boîtes noires
exactement comme aujourd'hui qui sont
les poisons et donc avec un apport
la question c'est est-ce qu'on continue
comme ça faire cette course à
l'empoisement elle empoisonnement qui
n'a ni que ni tête en fait qui ne
fonctionne pas je rappelle qu'il y a un
documentaire sur Arte exceptionnel sur
l'état de la recherche sur les rats donc
il s'appelle les rats tout au monde il y
a des chercheurs avant couvert qui
disent carrément qui le disent que
l'empoisonnement en fait provoque plus
de problèmes sanitaires parce qu'avec on
détruit les groupes sociaux de rats et
qu'ensuite ils vont se mélanger et donc
en fait c'est contre-productif c'est ça
qu'on veut dire attends donc nous on
n'est pas contre le fait d'utiliser des
méthodes la question c'est quel type de
méthode et nous ce qu'on voudrait
appeler on a eu on a écrit au Ministère
de la Recherche pour leur en parler on a
eu rendez-vous aussi à Matignon on
voudrait vraiment qu'il y a de la
finance de des finances de la recherche
publique pour développer les méthodes
non létales éthique efficaces c'est
possible je veux dire aujourd'hui on
s'est envoyé des humains sur la lune je
pense qu'on va savoir limiter la
reproduction des rares il faut arrêter
de dire tout et n'importe quoi
moi j'aime bien ce que vous faites je
trouve que vos actions elles sont
intelligentes toujours mais là il y a
quand même un petit côté il y a il y a
quand même un petit côté provocateur
c'est à dire qu'il y a des déchets il y
a des rats et vous surfer un peu sur la
vague alors merci beaucoup d'en parler
merci beaucoup d'en parler cette
manifestation était prévue bien avant
en effet le Parisien pour faire un petit
peu de choses je sais pas quoi créer une
polémique mais ça n'avait encore rapport
en fait il se trouve quand les programmé
bien avant si on applique si on
appliquait vos méthodes ça prendrait
combien de temps pour endiguer cette
prolifération massive alors le bah en
fait la question c'est toujours la même
c'est que les méthodes contraceptives
elles sont efficaces mais évidemment il
faut le dire les choses honnêtement
elles vont entrer en concurrence avec le
fait que les rats se nourrissent par les
déchets est-ce que ça peut évidemment il
y a un problème de gestion des déchets
il faut que les deux soient mises en
place en même temps mais le cycle des
rats est de cycle de reproduction est
assez court donc ça on peut voir une
différence assez rapidement en ce moment
excusez-moi monsieur je m'en vais un
autre mec qui vient qui passe
une question en ce moment est-ce que
c'est bien le moment de dépenser des
millions d'euros pour trouver une
méthode pour être éradiquer les rats de
façon simple honnêtement franchement
c'est est-ce qu'on est satisfait de la
situation
c'est à savoir pourquoi ils ne le font
pas la technique que vous pensez la
meilleure est-ce que c'est pas une
question d'argent est-ce que c'est pas
plus cher de leur donner une pilule que
de les tuer directement non c'est qu'en
fait aujourd'hui il y a qu'un seul
produit qui est sur le marché en terme
de contraceptif pour les rats luminaires
qui est disponible aux États-Unis qui
n'est pas disponible sur le marché de
l'Union européenne donc on demande qu'il
y a une entreprise aux alentours
européenne qui le mettent en place mais
c'est surtout qu'en fait on est dans une
habitude il faut dire les choses
aujourd'hui les animaux dès qu'il nous
dérange on les tue voilà on ne sait
faire que ça on ne sait pas faire autre
parce que ce produit n'est pas encore en
France c'est ça exactement on souhaite
qu'une entreprise française européenne
qui développe ce produit avec un soutien
je sais pas comment selon vous
donc selon vous le rat ça n'est pas du
tout dangereux dans les jardins
d'enfance si des enfants on va pas bien
en fait c'est alors mal de compagnie
comme un autre alors c'est pas l'animal
de compagnie puisque là il est dans la
rue donc c'est un animal liminaire mais
alors les les tous les animaux peuvent
prendre des maladies déjà je tiens à le
dire à tous les animaux donc les chiens
les chats aujourd'hui je rappelle qu'en
France il y a 10000 morts sur de chiens
par an est-ce qu'on tue tous les chiens
non donc les les cas de transmission de
maladie des rats existent mais sont
extrêmement rares je vous donne un
exemple très simple donc la maladie qui
est la plus transmissible par les rats
par l'urine donc il faut avoir en
contact direct avec l'urine donc par une
plaie ou par la bouche etc c'est la
lecture spirose ok il y a 700 cas par an
et on estime qu'à peu près 42 morts 42
morts par an elle est aussi rose elle
est aussi transmise par des animaux
42 morts par an et je vous donne un
autre exemple de qui pour moi un
problème majeur de santé publique en
France il y a 40000 morts de pollution
de l'air liée aux particules fines mais
ça ça m'intéresse d'accord
le risque sanitaire je n'ai pas qu'il
existe pas mais il faut arrêter de dire
que c'est
un autre animal et ce qui ce qu'il y a
d'autres animaux qui tuent en France
des maladies et il peut y avoir des
problématiques beaucoup plus choléra je
rappelle quand même que contrairement à
ce que pense Cyril je vais quand même le
dire les rats quand ils nous voient il
fuit ils ne vont pas vous sauter dessus
mais peut-être que moi
sont extrêmement sympathique et qu'il
préfère aider un congénère
qui sont venus prendre les cartes
morts quand ils sont cachés alors
imaginez si on les laisse proliférer il
y en aura cachés
[Rires]
mais on joue pas à la balle avec Cara on
prend une passion rat en laisse on fait
ça des câlins
j'adore les chatouilles et pour
information quand vous faites des
chatouilles des rats en fait ils
rigolent mais c'est que trace au nord on
ne l'entend pas
on tapé cinq comme ça avec la tepac
comme un site taper ça ma vie tu sais
quoi
ok mais c'est pas la même chose
la question c'est qu'on veut des
méthodes qui sont éthiques et efficaces
ensuite juste j'insiste un truc très
important il faut arrêter de dire des
nombres de rats il n'y a pas d'études
scientifiquement une étude du musée
naturel dure 3 ans qui va pas être très
important me donne une bonne info
Rachman quelle est la source de ratmann
c'est le roi des rares frère il a dit
les
maladies et virus que ça a doublé en un
an ça a doublé en un an alors
ce qui a augmenté à cause du
réchauffement climatique et je rappelle
qu'elle est inspirose en fait il y a des
grosses disparités régionales et qu'elle
est beaucoup plus présente dans le sud
de la France et en France
notamment un abattoir et la leptospirose
il y a un vaccin pour tous les
professions à risque donc les égoutiers
abattoirs il y a un traitement quand
c'est détecté il y a un traitement on
peut en guéri sauf pour les personnes
qui ont très faible système immunitaire
aujourd'hui vous avez dit il y a pas
d'étude fiable les dernières estimations
qui tombent pas de n'importe où
maintenant on sera 6000 tours
merci Christine Denis qui est professeur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
naturel a dit que tous les chiffres
donnés étaient fantaisistes
dans un an ou deux le Muséum d'Histoire
Naturelle nous dira combien il y aura
Paris pourrait dire un nombre comment
n'importe quoi
je connais ce chiffre c'est Castaldi qui
a perdu ça sur son professeur
oui c'est ce que les sociétés de
dératisation commencent à dire il y
aurait cinq ou six millions maintenant
dans Paris
exemple vous savez à 13 je l'avais je
l'avais déjà dit mais donc à New York il
y a une étude qui a été faite il y a un
statisticien qui a compté le nombre de
rats Steven de New York non
il a été démontré que en fait il y en
avait 2 millions sur une population de 9
millions de New Yorkais donc en fait
c'est voilà c'est beaucoup moins que ça
ils ont agi vous le disiez vous-même
de manière éthique efficace et ensuite
je voudrais dire un truc important c'est
que déjà je voudrais quand même le
rappeler parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on a tendance oublié mais les rats ne
sont pas responsables de la crise
sociale en France premièrement je tiens
à le dire et ensuite là on critique le
fait que les rats en effet vont manger
les dossiers et c'est vrai mais en même
temps je rappelle quand même faudrait
savoir ce qu'on veut que le musée des
égouts de Paris dit que les rats
participent à la diminution des déchets
et parti pour
elle invite à table on est un peu dans
le monde de ratatouille avec vous je
pense qu'il y a aussi un problème qui
est structurel qui est la question en
fait de l'habitat insalubre et le fait
que si les rats en fait arrivent à
rentrer c'est aussi qu'il faut fermer
les les trous etc et sur la restauration
ce qui est très important évidemment
c'est que et pour nous aussi à la maison
il faut que tout soit en boîte
hermétique évidemment il faut pas qu'il
y a un accès comme ça
dans une boulangerie qui mange un
sandwich au jambon vous aimez bien ou
venir non mais c'est vrai c'est arrivé
là évidemment ça monte soyons très clair
je veux dire personne
qui moi je dis que il faut agir de
manière éthique et tiens aujourd'hui en
fait on se pose pas la question de
l'efficacité enfin je veux dire faudrait
que tout le monde soit révolté donc il
faut voter
c'est mort on doubler en un an on verra
dans un an ce sera catastrophique encore
plus car il y a il y a pas de travaux et
ni la grève des éboueurs je précise
je voudrais quand même dire à Rajman de
nous on demande on demande à la mère de
Paris on demande à la maire de Paris
[Rires]
de mettre en place un groupe de travail
pluridisciplinaire avec des experts pour
expérimenter les méthodes non létales
donc on n'a pas eu de réponse on demande
à Anne Hidalgo de nous répondre parce
que nous on est là aussi pour faire
avancer le sujet de manière apaisée
c'est-à-dire que on peut en rigoler ça
va 5 minutes mais l'idée c'est comment
faire pour avancer de manière ici
c'est vrai que comme Paris c'est la
capitale et qu'on parle que des rats à
Paris c'est un peu simplement mais